let's have a look at this together
because i've got to give you an
additional instruction now for what to
do with what you've done
we've got the graph of y equals sine x
on here okay and what i want to put on
top of this in much the same way that we
did this here i want to kind of
superimpose
what the gradient function looks like
like on the exponential in the log but
we're going to do this for y equals sine
x and then hopefully you'll actually be
able to see
how we do this for the others
okay we said right at the beginning
there when x equals zero so that's the
um that's the first one right it looks
pretty clear to all of us that the
gradient was equal to one yeah so you
can see where one is on this it's up
there up the top so what i'd love you to
do and if you have another color that's
just a bonus but i get to cheat and use
16.7 million colors go ahead and put an
x
corresponding to x equals zero put a
little x mark
up at one so this this purple is going
to indicate my derivative or my gradient
i should say at each point okay so when
x equals 0 so that's why you can see i'm
vertically above the origin there
the gradient is equal to 1.
and then as i go along i'm going to get
different gradients now i'm going to
skip right over to this one here first
because um hopefully a lot of you did it
and it's also easy
at this spot up here
if you draw the tangent what does it
look like
it's just yeah very good it's horizontal
right now horizontal line has a gradient
of
zero so because there's no rise right so
it's no rise over run so therefore back
with my original color and where my x is
going to go
this value here by the way what is this
x equals x equals
you can actually see if i zoom out a
little bit if this is pi over here on
the right then i'm kind of right in the
middle of this hill as it were so it
should be pi
divided by two right so in fact i'll
just um don't make this too busy but
drawing vertically down
i've got at x equals pi on two
i've got my gradient being equal to zero
okay so remember vertically we're saying
where it is 0 pi on 2 is where it is
horizontally
now i want to understand what's going on
in the middle okay now what i'd love you
to give me is can you supply me an x
value like say 0.2 or 0.1 or whatever it
happens to be oh that's a bit cheeky
isn't it that really should be 0.4
did you guys notice that and just no one
picked me up on it
you did you i wasn't saying anything
like say it mr wu you're wrong like come
on like throw a sharp implant at me or
something like that um pick an x value
0.2 0.4 0.6 whatever it is and can you
tell me
what the gradient is and i'm going to
plot it and we're all going to plot it
together in fact someone got some x
value between
norton i mean that's like 1.57 ish
and you can provide me a gradient ain't
takers
come on i just gave you like seven eight
minutes for this you can find a spot any
spot and it's just a measurement
anyone
i'll give you a clue
the gradient's gonna be between one
and zero
because somewhere you can see it's going
to be less than one that's the steepest
it gets
and zero is the shallowest it gets in
that section what do you think
am i gonna have to do one like on the
spot come on guys
all right fine we're doing this okay
here we go i'm gonna pick a spot like
say here
right uh that's what does that look like
1.2
1.2
and when you have a look at the gradient
there
if i draw that up like so
now this is all like busy and crowded
because i was relying on you guys but
well
uh
if you want to get something done to
yourself um have a look i've picked out
this measurement at 0.4 across
and when you do this vertically right
when you do this vertically does that
almost look like one full square it's
just kind of offset yeah so i think we
said that's like 0.2 or so okay so
therefore if i do rise over run 0.2
divided by 0.4 what's the value that you
get
0.2 divided by okay i refuse to not take
a volunteer for this one because we can
do this we learnt this in life you're
seven and eight zero point two divided
by zero point four you're all going to
tell me aloud together count of three
one two three
thank you so you did know okay so
for a half this is the gradient i'm
expecting
okay i'm gonna plot with purple where
a half is which looks like it's around
there yeah except it corresponds to
about
this spot like so
okay now because i actually know the
graph because i've done this a million
times that i'm going to be looking for i
know where the rest of these points are
roughly going to go and i invite you now
even if you're not going to tell me what
they are i can't ask you because you
have all different spots but you're
going to end up with values somewhat
like this
right do you see this kind of
uh
this this line that i can plot through
it's not a straight line though is it
right it's not straight it's sort of got
this gentle curve to it and as you go
along see at this spot here
this is an easy one tell me what
gradient you measured when you went to x
equals pi
it's negative one because look you're
decreasing and really there's this huge
amount of symmetry in the trigonometric
graphs right so it's really the opposite
of the positive one you measured at the
origin here's a negative one right so
therefore i'm going to get something
down here
and you're going to have again values
sort of much like this right
so again if you look at where my purple
x's are and you're going to have some
x's flowing as well you get from one all
the way down to negative one but you
don't get there via a straight line do
you right it's this kind of wiggly curve
can you go ahead and join the dots for
me and tell me what you think
that looks like i'm going to do my best
if you've got a pencil there it's
obviously tons easier
but i'm not too dissatisfied with that
what do you think
so look roughly like the points that
you've got
and again just referencing this symmetry
that we said before right see how
between zero and pi you're going up and
then going down
which corresponds to the fact that the
gradient is let's have a look at it the
gradient is positive here and then it's
negative here right going up going down
you get exactly the same thing but
backwards over here between pi and 2 pi
do you see that you're going down
then you're going up and that should
correspond to a gradient that is
negative and then positive so again i'm
going to pop a few points on here that
i'm aware of so here i should be zero
back here i should be up to one again
again you can put a few more x's on here
if you want but i already know where i'm
headed so i'm going to do my best to
thread that needle now i can do better
than that
let's try again
are you happy with that is that
reasonably satisfactory
so what have we done here right we've
been trying to gain intuition for what
the derivative of sine x which is in
black
looks like this is my gradient function
in purple this is my d y on dx at least
approx an approximation of it
please tell me you recognize that this
purple graph looks like something you've
been dealing with for a long time what
is it
that's that's cosine right at least it
looks suspiciously a lot like it should
be cosine it goes from the same values
starts at the same spot goes down to the
same spot you can put into your
calculator and verify these values okay
now we actually can do this symbolically
but i actually think for now it's not
necessary this intuition is enough so if
what you wanted was a heading from
before go to your book now and you can
stick that piece of paper in somewhere
nearby the heading is differentiating
trigonometric functions and what we've
got an intuition for now
is that
if you differentiate
sine x
what you end up with
is cos x like what else could that be
it's got or it goes through all the
right points it's also periodic just
like sine is right so like sign keeps on
going and going the gradient assign will
also keep going and going just at a
slightly different spot
okay
now underneath this
we have this question of well this is
not the only trigonometric function
right we said all of the rest of them
would come along for the ride
so underneath this this time i'm going
to ask you
to provide the graph you did just draw
cos x so hopefully we can do a
reasonably good job of it
here's cos x it's this valley looking
shape from naught
to 2 pi
what would the gradient of this look
like i'm going to ask you to have a go
and plot again where those values are
going to be i'll give you some clues
there are easy spots where you can see
the gradient is just like the graph that
you just did right
for example can you tell me there's
three x values and you can look up on
the board for me right
there are three x values where you can
immediately see
the gradient will be zero the tangent
will be horizontal the gradient will be
zero
can you give me those three x values
just by looking at it
i mean i've actually already given you
one of them
go ahead yeah
zero
very good there's a horizontal tangent
right there
pi which i haven't marked in
there's a horizontal tangent right there
and then the last one is 2 pi right you
can draw that horizontal tangent
so therefore for those three points 0 pi
and 2 pi
the gradient i'm going to put the x's
here again to indicate gradient should
be zero
but what about in between those spots
what will the gradient look like for
this section from naught to pi
for this section from pi to two pi
take a couple of minutes draw it onto a
graph just like i have put your x's and
then join the dots and tell me what you
think that looks like
okay
did you get something that looks roughly
like this i haven't threaded the needle
yet but you can see before i go on to
there you can see why i've gotten these
values between x equals zero and x
equals pi
the gradient has to be negative can you
see that how do you know
when you look at the graph how do you
know it has to be negative
yeah it's slanting down that's what
negative gradient means right you start
high you end up low so that's why all of
these green x's are negative they're
below the axis because the gradient is
negative so you end up with something
rather like that that's not bad okay now
when you go to the other side this is
all positive you see you're entirely
climbing through this section
but it's sort of like climbing at
different rates right
have a look at this with me when we
differentiated visually the sine curve
we ended up with cos
this is us trying that same trick
on cause
this green graph though
what is that green graph because
this green graph
[Music]
it's not there we go
it's not this sign x curve is it because
the sine x curve goes up first and then
it comes down
what is this
it's it's this but upside down do you
agree think back to graphing this is not
sine x
this is d y on dx equals
minus
sine x it's the upside down version does
that make sense
so this is a little bit weird you can
see this is going to be a little bit
tricky on your memory as you start to
learn and memorize these rules but you
can see it visually why you get this
result it flips around
versus this one okay
one last one before i then send you on a
very very brief break
sign and cause and then in year nine you
learn one other basic trig function
which was
tan
now
i highlighted the fact in fact i'm going
to go there right now i highlighted the
fact the 10 is an abbreviation
it's actually
10 is really shorthand for
sine
over cos
now some of you are going to be like oh
no mister don't do it to me and i am
going to do it to you right that
function there
is a fraction
it's a fraction
when you have a function you're
differentiating that looks like a
fraction you did it just this morning
twice i think
what rule do you use
it's it's a question so you use the
quotient rule so i'm going to call this
u
i'm going to call this
v and we're going to work out the
derivative together here we go
it's going to be v u dash minus u v dash
all over v squared let's do it step by
step
v that's just going to be cos
x
what's u dash
have a look
this is oopsy does he
if that's you
then u dash is just going to be
cos
v u dash
take away
u is sine x
and if this is v
cos x then what is v dash
it's minus sign x
this is looking weird and symmetrical
and then lastly all on the denominator
it's a really bad line but sorry it's
going to be v squared right so we would
write that as cos squared
x all right
let's tidy this this kind of mess up
right up in the top
cos x times cos x you could write that
as cos squared what happens to those
negatives
they cancel
so you just get sine
squared x does that
look familiar think back to the
identities that you've learned what's
cos squared plus sine squared equal to
yeah that's equal to one
if that's kind of like wait a second
where did that come from i will come
back to this identity later on it's the
pythagorean identity super important and
this i'm happy with but
again mathematicians being famously lazy
we say i've got a name for this when
you've got cos on the denominator it's
one of these
um
reciprocal functions
now i don't know if some of you have
encountered this before but there's a
really easy way to remember which
reciprocal is which does anyone know
what that trick is yeah
yeah it's completely coincidental which
i don't like there's no reason for it
really but if you look at that third
letter there
sine cos
tan so i want cos which is this one
right so therefore you would write this
as a sec
squared
x that's the derivative